- Basically all it takes
to silence the majority
is a very loud, very aggressive
and intransigent minority.
It can re-normalize an
entire institution by using,
by getting maybe 20% of
people inside an institution
to be very loud
and very solidified
and repeating the same thing
over and over and over.
Which of course is what
the left is very good at.
And you can see this
happen in your own life.
Like the example that's used
by Nassim Nicholas Taleb
is the example of you have a
family of four and the daughter
decides one day
she's vegetarian.
So she comes home, she says
to mom, "I'm vegetarian
and I want a vegetarian meal."
And mom says, "Okay well I
can either make two meals,
one that's vegetarian for
her and one that's good
for everybody else, or
I can make a vegetarian
meal for everyone."
And so mom decides,
I'm making a vegetarian
meal for everyone.
Well daughter has now
re-normalized the family.
The family is now vegetarian
because daughter
was intransigent.
And you can expand
that outward, right?
The whole family now wants
to go to a block party,
they say to the person
at the block party,
"We need a vegetarian meal for
us because of our daughter,"
and the person says, "Okay,
do I really wanna, you know,
go out and buy two meals.
I'll buy one meal."
Now everybody's vegetarian
'cause of this one person.
You can see that sort
of stuff happening
inside our institutions.
It requires intransigence
and it requires solidity.
You can't move on the position,
you have to be
really intransigent
and the imposition that
you're making on somebody
has to be just minor enough
that they don't really fight
back against you.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is the founding
editor in chief of
the "Daily Wire,"
the host of "The
Ben Shapiro Show,"
author of the new book
"The Authoritarian Moment:
How the Left Weaponized
America's Institutions
Against Dissent,"
and the fastest talking
Jew on all of the internet.
Ben Shapiro, welcome back
to "The Rubin Report."
- Hey, good to talk to you.
- All right, my friend.
First off, I googled
that and you did come up
as fastest talking
Jew on the internet.
How do you feel about that?
- I mean, accurate.
Also, I don't know whether
to be flattered or insulted,
but it is what it is.
Life, reality, facts don't
care about my feelings.
It's all right.
- Facts do not care
about your feelings.
All right, so look,
we're gonna get
into the book, obviously.
This is what, your
87th book or 95th,
or where are we at now?
- Yeah, something like that.
I can never remember.
It's either my 11th or 12th,
depending on the count.
- Yeah.
It's a lot of books.
As a guy who just finished
my second, I admire someone
that has written
this many books.
But let's just start
sorta just generally
with what's going
on in the world,
which will kind of
get us to the book,
because that's really
what this is all about.
COVID's a little
bananas right now,
or at least the
reaction to COVID.
Where are you at at this
point with the whole thing?
- So the pandemic is over
as far as I'm concerned
from a public
policy perspective.
That does not mean that the
pandemic is like technically
over, like, you can walk
outside without vaccination,
without masks,
everything's fine.
But what it does mean is that
all public policy is designed
to do is achieve
certain objectives.
Originally we were told
that the public policy
with regard to COVID
was designed to prevent
the overrunning
of the hospitals.
And so we all locked
down and we all masked up
and then we prevented the
overrunning of the hospitals.
And then the idea was okay,
well now we're gonna delay
indefinitely until we
can get to the vaccine.
And then these miraculous
vaccines came around
and the idea was okay, the
vaccines are now available.
And then we said, okay,
well we'll until every adult
has had the chance to either
take it or not take it
as the case may be because
they are super duper effective.
And now we've reached that.
And now the problem is
there's no actual next goal.
And this is something that
is driving me up a wall.
If you listen to
people on CNN or MSNBC
or on the administration
talk, it seems that the goal
is zero COVID.
Like every single person
in the United States
getting the vaccine and
then COVID just going away.
And no one actually thinks
this is ever going to happen.
This is a disease that has
been seeded over every country
pretty much on planet earth.
It's taken a minimum
of four million lives,
probably closer to six million
if you look at the
actual stats from India.
And certainly if you
include the actual number
of dead from China, a
lot more lives than that.
And the notion that this
is just going to go away
if we yell at people to
get the vaccine, is crazy.
Which means to me that
basically now that every adult
has had the opportunity
to take the vaccine
and because, thank God, this
disease is not really affecting
kids in severe ways,
like the total number
of kids under the age
of 18 who have died
is still under 350 in a
sub-population of 75 million,
we're done.
I mean, as far as public, what
public policy can accomplish
or should seek to accomplish,
we are pretty much done
at this point.
And the problem for the left
is that they set, as a goal,
the idea of zero
COVID back last year
and now they can't let go of it.
So Biden is kind of stuck
between a rock and a hard place.
On the one hand, he wants
to declare COVID over
so we can all go back to work
and everybody can enjoy life
and he can say that
he beat the thing.
On the other hand,
he's actually, in order
to do that he has to
acknowledge that we have to live
with the virus which would
open the can of worms
that last year Democrats
said we should certainly not
live with the virus and
anybody who said we should
live with the virus, like
governor DeSantis in Florida,
was bad and evil.
So instead we're gonna get
this ridiculous specter
of people trying to
scare you into being okay
with giving up liberties
that really, at this point,
there's no scientific
rationale for.
So you're gonna continue
masking your kid even though,
again, this thing is not
radically damaging to children.
I mean, 810 kids died of
pneumonia in the same period
that COVID killed
something like 350 kids
over the course of the
last year and a half or so.
You're supposed to mask
up your kid to protect
a 40 year old who decided
not to get the vaccine.
Or if you're vaccinated
you're supposed to mask up
in case, God forbid, you give
it to somebody who, again,
decided not to get the vaccine.
Like none of that is
good public policy.
So I'm annoyed by it.
I'm frustrated by it.
I also think it's a
bad incentive structure
because I don't know why I,
who according to the powers
that be did the right
thing, I got vaccinated.
My wife got vaccinated.
My parents got vaccinated.
Why am I supposed to
penalize myself by masking up
to protect people who are
overtly not only not vaccinating
but also saying they
don't care whether I wear
a mask or not.
It's bizarre.
- What would you say to
those people at this point?
Because there obviously
are a lot of people.
I think it might be as many
as something like 30 to 40%
of American adults
that are not vaccinated
that are saying I either had
it and I have the antibodies
or I just don't
want this vaccine,
which basically was
produced in about a year.
Or whatever reasons
that might have.
What would you say to
those people at this point?
- So number one, you're a free
and independent human being,
you're an adult, and
it's your decision.
That's that's number one.
Number two, if we're talking
about you already had COVID,
I certainly see the rationale,
there's some pretty good data
suggesting that natural
immunity is as strong,
if not stronger than
vaccine immunity.
What I would say is
that for a lot of people
the given evidence shows,
depending on your age
and depending on
your health factors,
that your rate of death
from COVID outweighs
the rate of adverse
effects from the vaccine
so far as the data
that we have yet seen.
And this is pretty much
true for everybody above
the age of 18.
I haven't seen the data
between 12 and 18 so much,
and certainly for kids.
I have very little interest
in vaccinating my seven, five
and one-year-old at this point.
But if you're 35 years
old or 40 years old
and you're saying, "Well, you
know, I thought I got COVID."
I'm hearing a lot of this.
"I thought I got COVID,
but I wasn't actually
tested for COVID.
I'm sure I had it before."
Well unless you were
tested for it, it might've
been something else.
Right?
There are a lot of other
sicknesses going around.
I was sick several times
during the COVID pandemic,
never got COVID.
So don't rely on that.
Take into account
your own risk factors
and then seriously consider
getting the vaccine.
Because, frankly, the
risks from the vaccine,
from what I'm seeing in the
data, are not particularly high.
And the risks from COVID
are, depending on your age
maybe somewhat higher, maybe
a multiple times higher.
But again, I respect your
abilities and individual choose
as long as you're willing to
live with the consequences.
If you don't get the vaccine
and then you get sick,
you know, that would
be a you problem,
don't don't come to public
policy seeking a solution.
- Right.
To that point though how
have in the last year
have you figured out
who you can trust
or what institutions
you can trust?
Because it seems to me we've
just seen a complete collapse
across the board, political,
cultural, you know,
journalistic, just
the entire thing
has completely collapsed.
And that's what people ask me
almost more than anything else
at this point, "Dave,
who do you trust?
How do you figure out how
to make some sense of this?"
- I mean the way that I
determine who to trust
is whether people were skeptical
of the official narrative
but were basing that in data.
So, for example, one of the
people who I personally trust,
a guy named Dr. Marty Makary
from Johns Hopkins' University.
Very early on, he and I
talked pretty much every week
on the show.
And very early on, he was very
skeptical of the lockdowns.
He was very
skeptical of the idea
that if you're 20 years old
you shouldn't be working
or that we should be not
treating people who are 20
in a different way than
we were treating people
who are 70, for example.
Because he was skeptical
of that but he was taking
the science pretty seriously
I had a lot of respect for that.
Same thing with Jay
Bhattacharya from Stanford.
If you just bought hook, line
and sinker the actual official
narrative throughout
and the idea,
and you never cited the data.
If you ever at any point
said, "The science says..."
Then I have pretty
much a problem with you
because science is a process,
science is not a person
or an institution.
And so there's sort of a
group of people who I think
were skeptical of
some of the narratives
and who would do a good job.
It similar you decide
who to trust in politics.
They do a good job sort of
steel manning the other argument
and then say, "Okay,
and here's where I think
the flaws are."
And they'd give a nuanced
picture of the data
as opposed to people who are
just like, "You listen to me,
and if you don't listen
to me, you're an idiot."
In which case I think pretty
much always you don't listen
to those people.
- Right, so this will kind
of segue us to the book,
but are you surprised
in the last year,
I remember like two or
three weeks into COVID,
it was one of the many
times in the past year
that Ben Shapiro has
trended on Twitter
because you said the
very obvious statement,
in essence that we
are gonna have to live
with a certain amount of death.
A certain amount is,
it's just what actuaries
have to deal with when they're
figuring out insurance rates.
And that's just the
reality of life.
And of course everyone
in Media Matters
and all the usual
clowns were saying
that Ben Shapiro wants
to kill old people
and everything else.
But are you, related to that,
are you sort of surprised
how quickly everyone folded?
And even now you can sense
that there's a certain amount
of people in the media
that want lockdowns again,
they want more
government programs.
Like they just, they're
getting off on this.
They just, they just like it.
- Yeah.
I mean, I think that
that is very true.
I think that this has become
almost a pagan worship ceremony
for a lot of people.
Because again, I'm
not anti-masking
under certain circumstances.
I'm not anti-masking
for un-vaccinated people
who are with other
un-vaccinated people
who are vulnerable to COVID.
I mean, I was never
anti-Fauci until he started
pretty much overtly lying to
us in a wide variety of cases.
I've been pro-vaccine
throughout this entire pandemic.
So yeah, I find it
shocking however the number
of people who are much more
interested in castigating
people who are using their own
independent risk assessment
and coming to a
different conclusion,
or analyzing the data
in a different way but
looking at the data.
I'm shocked at the number
of people who have decided
that they are more interested
in the partisan virtue
signaling than in even
examining the data.
That's the part that I
find really shocking.
And the eagerness with which
people are going back to,
"Well you're not masking."
This is where it's gonna go,
right, they're gonna say,
the CDC will issue some
sort of guidance saying
if you're vaccinated,
you ought to mask up.
And I'm going to say, no.
I've already said no.
I've vaccinated, I am not
transmitting the disease,
the numbers of people who are
asymptomatically transmitting
COVID while vaccinated
is very low.
The number of breakthrough
infections is very, very low.
According to the New York Times
there are 160 million people
vaccinated in the United States.
There've been something like
6,000 breakthrough cases.
I'm not masking up for that.
And most of all, it's one
thing to make the case
that I should mask up if
somebody can get the disease
through no fault of their own.
But if you've had the
opportunity to get a vaccine
and then you didn't and
then I give you COVID,
that one is kind of on you.
That's really not on me anymore.
But there will be this
move, like, if somebody says
that you need to mask up
despite being vaccinated
and you say no, then
it will be back to,
"Oh, you're willing
to kill grandma."
It's like, "No, I was never
willing to kill grandma."
But it's become much
more about the partisan.
It's why you see people
yelling at people
who are un-vaccinated, right?
It's not because they actually
want to convince those people
to vaccinate, if you want to
convince somebody to vaccinate
you do what I said
earlier, where you treat
them as an individual human
being, you take a look
at their risk factors,
you try to analyze
those on an individual
level and assuage the fears.
If you want to create
a sort of polarized,
you're a bad person,
I'm a good person thing,
then when you say you're
an idiot and a moron
if you don't vaccinate on
my timeline as I see fit
and no matter your
prior health scenario.
- Right, you'll be proud
to know Ben, as a refugee
of Los Angeles, that, you
know, we have this mask mandate
in effect again.
And I went to a
restaurant this weekend,
I went to Home Depot this
weekend and I went to a mall
this weekend and I
did not wear a mask.
And guess what?
An awful lot of people nodded
at me, you know, in support,
a lot of people were
not wearing masks.
And yes, when I went
into Bloomingdale's
and they asked me to
put the mask on, I did
because I'm not trying
to get somebody fired
or get into a fight
with somebody.
But I bring it up
because enough people
are sort of like, "Okay,
it is time to move on."
And that's just where
we're at at the moment.
- Yeah.
Well, again, I moved to Florida
and I will tell you this,
if they try this
whole vaccinated need
to mask up again,
nobody's doing it.
I mean people weren't
doing it originally here.
I can't imagine that people
are gonna do it here.
And again, you know, Governor
DeSantis has been very big
on everybody should
get the vaccine,
if you are physically
able to get the vaccine.
And there's not much more
than that, that he can do.
And I'm just, I gotta
say, just on a data level
I'm bewildered by this.
I was looking at the
seven day running average
of death from COVID,
the average number
of deaths from COVID, according
to the New York Times,
seven day rolling
average right now is 269.
Okay, when we were at the
height of the pandemic,
it was well over 3,000
people a day who were dying.
So we've brought down that
factor by a factor of 10.
Okay, we are now seeing
fewer people die every day
in the United States
from COVID than die
on a normal day from diabetes.
- Right, and 269, 269, I
mean, are they giving us ages
on that or other health, you
know, the comorbidity stuff?
Because that's a
very small number.
Of course we don't
want people to die,
but it's a small number.
- Well, I mean, again,
if you are going to talk
about public health crises
then you really do have to talk
about the number of
people who are dying
and the number of people
who are being hospitalized.
And the fact that the media
will do things like play
with stats where they'll say,
"Well, you know, we've had
a 40% increase in the
number of hospitalized
from three weeks ago."
And it's like, "Yes, but
the number of hospitalized
three weeks ago was
very, very low."
Like a 40% increase means
we are still very, very low.
So this doesn't mean
that we're making light
of any of this sort of stuff.
What it does mean is that
statistically speaking
the people who are getting
serious breakthrough infections
have significant
underlying illnesses,
very significant
and the people who are
mostly getting hospitalized
dying tend to be people
who are un-vaccinated.
And that really resides in
sort of the middle section
of the age range
for the population
because, dirty little
secret, pretty much everybody
who's over the age of 65 in
this country got the vaccine.
- Yeah.
Ben, I'm not an
mathemagician like you are,
but if there's one
person who had COVID
and then the next
week there's two,
what's the percent
increase on that?
- That's a 100% increase.
Right?
- My God, that's a
huge, huge increase.
All right, well all of
this leads us perfectly
to "The Authoritarian
Moment" because it does seem
like we are in it right now.
Are you sort of having a pat
yourself on the back moment?
'Cause I've been feeling
that a little bit lately.
Like we were in a group of
people that were screaming
about all of this
about five years ago.
Not to say there weren't plenty
of people doing it before that.
But like we were really on
the internet like front end
of like "Guys, this
horrible thing is here."
And everyone kept saying,
"No, no, it's just
on college campuses."
And now it has burst
forth for everyone to see.
- Yeah, no question.
I mean, you know, I used to
think, as a religious Jew
there's a whole
take on prophecy,
that prophecy is like
God speaking through you,
but I tend to think now
that prophecy is more along
(indistinct) lines.
Just seeing very clearly
what's happening right now.
I mean, I think the reason
that that Orwell's "1984"
is prophetic is not
because it was prophecy,
it's because he was
actually describing a thing
that was happening in the
Soviet Union at the time.
And so when we look at
things happening elsewhere,
like, "Wow, how
could he foresee it?"
He wasn't foreseeing anything,
he was literally describing.
And describing what's going
on, you know, five years ago
and then looking
what's happening.
It was a smaller
phenomenon then,
it's a much larger
phenomenon now.
And I don't think any
of us were prophets,
I think that we just all saw
clearly what was happening
and the direction that
people were moving.
And the authoritarianism
that I talk about in the book
is really not the government
top-down authoritarianism
that we've worried
about in the past.
The idea the government is
gonna tell you what to do,
although that may be
the natural outgrowth
of a sort of attitudinal
authoritarianism
that's taken over.
What I'm talking about more
is all of the institutions
of society, the
non-governmental institutions
of society in large
part becoming more
and more intolerant
of dissent, outlawing
descent, social ostracization,
people losing their jobs,
people having family members
not speaking to them anymore.
And this is leading to
a complete breakdown
in the possibility of us even
having a republic together.
It's really, really
dangerous stuff.
And everybody feels it.
This is the part that's
amazing is that we're all being
gaslit by the media that
says that this stuff
is not important or that,
you know, it's just making
the country better.
But by polling data,
every single subgroup
in the United States,
including mainstream liberals,
with the exception
of far-left radicals,
with the exception of the far
left every single subgroup
in the United States says
they are afraid to say
what they believe about
politics publicly.
That's insane.
Okay.
That is a good indicator
of where we are
and how far we have to go.
- What do you make of the
last liberals at this point?
I mean do you consider them
part of a new conservative
movement or some sort of
wide tent thing on the right?
I mean that's what I would say.
I'm not talking about
obviously the crazy lefties,
but the last few, the Sam
Harris the Barry Weiss,
whoever else is left.
Like what do you make of
that crew at this point?
- I mean, so frankly I
think that the future
of the country rests
on them because I think
that the folks in the middle
are gonna have to
make a decision.
There are a lot of
sort of mainstream
establishment liberals
who have a decision to make.
The decision is this,
they can either move along
with the hardcore left with
whom they agree on policy
a lot of the time, and they
can get their left-wing utopia
at the expense of
individual rights, comedy,
having a country, or they
can say to the radical left,
"Look, we may agree with
you on a lot of your policy
prescriptions but the way
you're going about this
is going to break the
country and we need to have
these discussions with
people on the right,
we need to preserve
individual rights
and if it takes us longer
to get where we're going,
or maybe even if we
don't get there at all,
the higher principles are
still worth standing up for."
I am unsure of which way
the establishment liberals
are going to go.
Because you do see things
like the Harper's letter
with 150 liberal
intellectuals saying
that they are very much in
favor of individual rights.
It would have been nice
to see one Trump supporter
on that list.
It would also be nice to know
really whether mainstream
establishment liberals
are interested in opening
the Overton window
wider than themselves.
In other words, are they saying,
"We don't like cancel
culture for us."
Or are they saying, "We
don't like cancel culture,
even for people with
whom we disagree."
So today on Twitter I put
out sort of a challenge,
maybe called the nice
bucket challenge,
but the basic challenge is if
you are a person in politics
can you name and publicly
say about somebody who voted
differently than you that
they're a nice person?
Can you say that?
Because the answer for a lot
of folks on the left is no.
The answer for a lot of,
and I'm including mainstream
liberals there, people who
just will not treat you
as a human being publicly.
They won't come out
and say publicly,
"I disagree with this
person on nearly everything,
they're a nice person, and
you should read their stuff
and consider it."
You say that kind of
crap all the time.
I say that all the time.
I literally refer people
to left wing podcasts
and say, "You should listen
to them and listen to me
and then decide who
you agree with."
I've never heard of
a left wing podcast
that has suggested anything
remotely similar about my own.
- Ben, because you're a Nazi.
- Right.
- Duh.
- Right, I mean
that's how it works.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I hate to tell you
that I think I can give you
the conclusion on
your hypothesis here,
which is that they're
not for the most part
gonna move in the direction
you want them to move.
I don't think they'll
necessarily move towards
the left anymore
but they'll stay
in this sort of
irrelevant limbo phase.
Because I've met, and
I, you know I know a lot
of these people, and they
just more than anything else,
more than saving the
country, they just don't want
to be called conservatives.
'Cause you guys are very scary.
You guys are very, very, very.
- I'd say it's a real problem
and it's why I opened the book
by talking about January 6th.
Because I think
that there's a trick
that's being played right now.
And it's why the Democrats are
trying to do the January 6th
commission, make a big
deal out of January 6th.
Listen, January
6th was a big deal,
but it was a big deal because
law enforcement failed
to stop a couple of
hundred idiots from running
into the Capitol building.
The notion that it was a full
scale assault on democracy,
that it was going to
end with the overthrow
of our democracy, the
worst democratic situation
since the Civil War
in the words of-
- Ben, AOC...
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
AOC said that we were an hour
away from armed insurrection,
or we were an hour away from
Marshall Law is what she said.
- Yeah, it's insane.
I mean it's totally
and utterly insane.
What I pose at the
beginning of the book
is a basic question.
Let me give you two
realities, okay?
One is we have January 6th,
it's an act of evil by a bunch
of idiots who are gonna be
arrested and go to jail.
Then we have an entire left wing
that labels the entire
right wing responsible
for January 6th, starts
suggesting overt social controls
with regard to media, with
regard to free speech,
starts de-platforming
places like Parler,
using neutral service providers
like Amazon Web Services,
start to openly moving to push
social media to ban people,
like mainstream
conservative voices,
starts talking to corporations
about how they're not allowed
to give any more to members
of the Republican party
who didn't vote the way
they wanted them to vote
on certification of the election
without actually
overthrowing the election.
Right?
Which one is more authoritarian?
A bunch of idiots running
into the Capitol building
and then getting
themselves arrested
or every major institution in
America declaring January 6th
such an unbelievable crisis
that they have to maximize
their power over your life?
I mean it seems to me that
there's a wild imbalance
in the amount of
institutional support
for one authoritarian
ideal versus the other.
- Right, and speaking of
Twitter, and today I just saw,
like within the last hour
that the ADL is now working
with PayPal to basically
hunt down white supremacists,
which will be basically
anyone who's not a lefty,
and then it's like, all
right, well now if you can't
be on PayPal what can't
you be on tomorrow?
Is it gonna be Chase Bank?
Is it gonna be some
other financial service?
And that white supremacist
thing will keep getting
wider and wider.
- Yeah, well, what the
left has succeeded in doing
is instead of just utilizing
the government to violate
the first amendment,
instead what they've done
is they've found a way to
pressure private companies
into doing it.
And this is really,
really dangerous stuff.
You're seeing this
with Facebook as well.
Obviously last week NPR
ran an entire piece,
it's a government funded
entity, they ran an entire piece
trying to push Facebook
into suppressing traffic
from my website.
They admit in the piece we
don't lie, they say we don't,
we don't engage in
conspiracy theorizing.
We openly admit at the
bottom of every single story
and say and brag about the fact
that we are openly conservative.
Like, and they should
suppress their traffic anyway.
Like they're not even trying
to hide it at this point.
And then they say, well it's
not a first amendment issue
if government entities or if
the White House is pushing
private actors to violate
your first amendment rights
because those private actors
are not government entities.
Okay, well if the government
is essentially chartering
an institution and then
restricting what the institution
can and cannot do with
the first amendment,
they've become a
government agent
and it's becoming
very, very dangerous.
- Is the real issue there
that we simply don't know
because it's like the whole
machine doesn't work anymore
and everything is
so filled with lies
that when Jen Psaki says
that the administration
is flagging posts for, that
was her words, for Facebook.
It's like, yeah, that
obviously to us seems
like some sort of
government coercion
related to a private
company if we're to believe
that Facebook is private.
But the bigger issue is it's
like how are we ever gonna
really find out
what they're doing?
'Cause there is no honest
actor to deal with it, right?
Like we're gonna have
another congressional hearing
to figure out what happened.
- That's exactly right.
And one of the biggest problems
here is that as we have
seen, and this was the really
kind of revelatory moment
of what happened with
Parler, for a while the line
from the left, and many
people on the right,
including people like me
on the libertarian right,
was, "Okay if you don't
like how Twitter handles
its business, go build
your own Twitter."
So then Parler built
its own Twitter
and then the neutral
service providers came along
and they were like, "Well,
what if we just deny
you neutral service?"
And so you can see how we
moved away from, you know,
there's sort of a baseline
of neutral service providers
and then you can build
it on top of that
and compete within
that structure to,
you have to build entirely
parallel mechanisms
that cost billions and billions
of dollars with, you know,
30 years of headstart from
the left on all of this stuff,
and the government standing
in the background pushing.
I mean that is extremely
dangerous stuff.
And again, the
predictable result
of all of this is
gonna be fragmentation
because people aren't
gonna go along with this
and you're going to,
you're seeing it right now.
You're seeing states cracking
down on Facebook, right?
Since when did Florida have
an interest in Facebook?
Since when does Texas
have an interest?
When these places started
basically mimicking
the line of the Democratic
party and states said,
"Okay, well, the federal
government is no longer
gonna protect our
citizens so I guess
we're gonna have to do it."
The fragmentation is upon
us unless people back away.
- Do you think that
fragmentation is good?
I mean, I'm sort of at the
point where, look, we have
a Federalist system
for a reason.
You moved to Florida
Like, let the
fragmentation occur,
let local governments
figure out what's good.
And then I would say,
perhaps we just need
a complete fragmentation
of the economy too.
And we'll just, I mean, you
know, I'm working on locals,
like we'll just build
different things.
And it kinda sucks, 'cause
I know that your gut feeling
is that we shouldn't go
that route but it's like,
I don't see an
alternative in a way.
- Yeah.
I mean, it may be
an eventuality.
So it's not
something I'd prefer,
I've said this over and
over and over again.
I would prefer that
we all be able to eat
at whatever restaurant we
want without having to worry
about the politics of the owner.
But if the left is
going to militarize
all of the institutions,
there's not gonna be a choice.
And, listen, on a personal
level, it's fine with me
because I'll make
plenty of money from it.
I have a huge platform
and if there's gonna be
a conservative razor company,
it'll probably be branded by us.
But at the same time, is
that good for the country?
Is it good that you can
identify your neighbor
by what, you know, what razor
they use in the morning?
Like, I don't think any of
that is good for the country.
And I also have real doubt
that, you know, when we talk
about the fragmentation,
the Federalist system,
the left is making
it increasingly clear
that they are not
going to abide by that.
Right, this is why they are
attempting to federalize
all the election procedures
because their idea is not,
"Okay, Texas does
what Texas does
and California does
what California does
and we share our country and
we have some baseline rules
at the top."
It's that Texas should not be
allowed to do what Texas does,
and Florida should not be
allowed to do what Florida does
and if you don't like it,
well, we're just gonna change
the law at the top line.
It's gonna lead to some
pretty significant conflict.
And that's when things
really start to get dangerous
as the left continues
to suck more power
up into the top level and then
cram down the California view
on Texas or Florida.
- Yeah.
So listen, I wanna go through
quickly each, you know,
a little bit on each chapter.
But I wanna jump to
chapter seven for a second
about fake news.
Because you mentioned
the election stuff
and one of the things I've
been doing on the show
in the last two, three
weeks is I've been reading
what's in these election bills.
What was in HB3 and in Texas,
what they're doing in Georgia.
And there's nothing racist.
In many cases, it allows
for more time to vote
and people to actually,
you know, for paper trails
and let's actually make
sure there's cameras
when we're counting.
I mean everything in these
bills, as far as I can see it,
is to make sure there
is more transparency.
But the reason I liken
this to chapter seven,
the fake news, is that
the media will not cover
these things honestly.
The media keeps telling
us these bills are racist,
they're about keeping black
and brown people from voting.
And no matter how many
times we expose them,
Jake Tapper is not going
to talk about that.
Brian Stelter is not
gonna talk about it.
The New York Times is
not gonna talk about it.
So what do we do?
- I mean, the only answer there
is that people in the state
seem to know this,
which is why they keep
electing Republicans.
I mean, like these election
security bills are very popular
in the states that they
are currently being passed.
And you're right.
I mean, the media are at
this point just open agents
of the Democratic party, pushing
the Democratic party line.
Whether it's all misinformation
ought to be banned online,
or whether it's all
these voter fraud,
all these voter fraud bills
are really about suppressing
the black vote.
Let me put it this way,
the amount of, the lie,
they keep saying it's the big
lie that voter fraud decided
the last election.
All right, if that's a big
lie, it's just as big a lie
that voter suppression is
widespread in the United States.
That is just an
overt, ridiculous lie.
There is no evidence to suggest
that black people are being
suppressed on a systematic
level and prevented from voting.
It's just not true.
There is no evidence
of it whatsoever.
And yet that's the basis
of the For the People Act.
So the Democrats are like,
"Well, you know, the lies
about January 6th and November
4th, those are leading
to all these voter fraud bills."
Okay, even if that were
true the lies that you guys
are telling about
voter suppression
have led to you trying
to federalize the entire
system in violation
of the constitution.
You're right, the media
lie about this stuff
on a routine basis and then
they obscure it by pretending
that they're objective.
But I think that their
day of dominance is ending
which is why, I think that the
discussion over the fake news
is actually secondary to the
discussion over social media,
because what's happened
is that it used to be,
they used to bookmark all
the sites that you wanted
to visit, and this is the
old way of doing things
in 2003, 2004, right.
You'd bookmark Drudge and
then you'd bookmark, you know,
the Huffington Post and
you'd actually check
all the different
sites individually.
Because everybody started
getting their news
through these feeds, whether
it's Facebook or Twitter,
the centralization
of news consumption,
one source, has allowed
the left to swoop in
and then try to bottleneck
the amount of information
that can get out
via these sources.
That's the part that's
really dangerous.
I'm not worried about
the New York Times being
a propaganda outfit.
They've been a propaganda outfit
as long as I've been alive.
I'm much more worried about
them trying to re-establish
a monopolistic control
of the dissemination
of information than I am
about them being who they are.
- Yeah, so to that point,
can you talk a little bit
about your position,
the difference between
say a purely libertarian
position on big tech
versus a conservative opinion?
Because this is now
becoming the hot thing.
It's like, maybe
there's no chance.
Maybe this ship has sailed
and we can't do anything
at this point.
I'm guessing you don't want,
or at least I've never heard
you say that you want, you
know, government regulators
with hard hats, you
know, walking into Google
to look at the algorithm.
But what do you think we should
or could do, if anything?
- So I think that the
pretty easy solution here
seems to be to make a minor
change to section 230.
And the minor change
would be to just get rid
of the catch all clause.
So if you'd take a look at
section 230, section 230 says
that we, that you are
relieved from liability
if you remove, for example,
obscenity or pornography
or violent material or anything
otherwise objectionable.
It's that anything
otherwise objectionable
that is the catchall provision.
And I understand why
this originally was.
Right, to understand why section
230 is drawn the way it is
you have to understand
the history a little bit.
Basically platforms
were created,
these platforms
were open platforms,
and then there was, and
you didn't have liability
for what was on the platform
so long as you didn't police
what was on the platform
because it was just
like a phone line.
Right?
What I say on the phone
line, if I threaten to murder
somebody, AT&T's not
responsible for that.
I'm responsible for that.
Okay, so platforms
were basically just
you post something,
the platform is not responsible
for the thing that you post.
Then there was a website
that started going in
and deleting all the
obscene material.
And the people who were
putting up the obscene material
they said, "You've now violated,
you're now a publisher.
Because you're editing
and you're deleting stuff,
this makes you a publisher.
So if somebody posts
something to defamatory
and you don't delete
it, you're a publisher,
you ought to be treated
with liability."
And so Congress said,
"Well, that seems weird
that if I decide to get rid
of obscenity it's now my job
to treat the entire
platform as a publisher."
Well the problem is that has
now been completely reversed.
The idea behind 230 was to
promulgate and allow people
to get rid of truly
objectionable material
while not absorbing
the liability
of becoming like the Daily
Wire or the New York Times,
having to fact check every post,
because it's an open platform.
Instead what the left did is
they reversed the polarity.
They said, "Well actually
the job now of section 230
is to make you
into a publisher."
Right?
"Now your job is to remove all
of the objectionable content,
including politically
objectionable content.
And we will threaten
you with getting rid
of all section 230 protections
if you don't get rid
of," quote unquote,
"misinformation."
Well the easy way to fix
this is to just get rid
of the otherwise
objectionable clause.
Meaning that you can get rid
of stuff that violates the law.
You can get rid of stuff
that is pornographic.
You can get rid of
repeated spam, for example.
But if you start
discriminating on the basis
of politics, you're
no longer a publisher,
you're no longer a platform,
now you're a publisher
and the liability attaches.
- But do you think we have a
government or any officials?
I mean, there's a couple of
Republicans talking about this,
you know, Mike Lee and
Jim Jordan, Ryan Paul.
I mean a few people.
But it's like, do you think
we have any political will
to actually ever do anything
other than have hearings
about this stuff?
Like you think they
can do something?
- Well the problem is that
everybody says they want
to do something but
the stuff they wanna do
is radically different.
So Democrats are not
in favor of getting rid
of the otherwise
objectionable clause
because that would do
what we're talking about,
it would open up the platforms.
Instead what they
would like to do
is close off the platform.
So what they would like to do
is treat Facebook as monopoly
and then have somebody sit
on top of the government,
like an Elizabeth
Warren appointee, and
decide what Facebook
can and cannot put up.
And that of course is
incredibly dangerous.
So you'll see these New York
Times articles where it's like,
"Ah, there's broad
spectrum agreement
that Facebook has
to be regulated."
Well, I mean, that's
really not correct.
I mean, the question
is what is the content
of the regulation?
It's like saying that my
child and I have an agreement
that there ought
to be consequences
for not doing your homework.
Yeah, my child's consequence
is that she would like
to be able to eat cookies.
My consequence is
she goes to her room.
Like we agree that there
ought to be consequences,
but these are wildly variant.
- Yeah, all right.
So let's just jump into each
chapter for a little bit.
We've sort of bounced around
through some of them already.
"How to Silence a
Majority," is chapter one
and it does feel like most
people have been silenced
just by their own
acquiescence to all of this.
- Yeah, that's right.
Basically all it takes
to silence a majority
is a very loud,
very aggressive and
intransigent minority.
You can re-normalize an
entire institution by using,
by getting maybe 20% of
people inside an institution
to be very loud
and very solidified
and repeating the same thing
over and over and over.
Which of course is what
the left is very good at.
And you can see this
happen in your own life.
Like the example that's used
by Nassim Nicholas Taleb
is the example of you have a
family of four and the daughter
decides one day
she's vegetarian.
So she comes home, she says
to mom, "I'm vegetarian
and I want a vegetarian meal."
And mom says, "Okay, well I
can either make two meals,
one that's vegetarian for her
and one that's good
for everybody else,
or I can make a vegetarian
meal for everyone."
And so mom decides I'm making
a vegetarian meal for everyone.
Well, daughter has now
re-normalized the family.
The family's now vegetarian
because daughter
was intransigent.
And you can expand
that outward, right?
The whole family now wants
to go to a block party,
they say to the person
at the block party,
"We need a vegetarian meal
for us, because our daughter."
And the person says, "Okay,
do I really want to, you know,
go out and buy two meals.
I'll buy one meal."
Now everybody's vegetarian
'cause of this one person.
You can see that sort
of stuff happening
inside our institutions.
It requires intransigence,
and it requires solidity.
You can't move on the position,
you have to be
really intransigent
and the imposition that
you're making on somebody
has to be just minor enough
that they don't really
fight back against you.
Right, it can't be something
where you like demand
that you're gonna be the,
that you are the captain,
like you run the place now.
It can't be that, it has to
be something where, you know,
we just want diversity training.
That's all we want.
We just want diversity training.
And if we get diversity
training, then we'll be happy
and we'll leave you alone
and won't go go make our HR
reports and won't file lawsuits
and everything will be good.
And people in the middle
are like, "Well, you know,
it's annoying but do
I really want to spend
my day doing this?"
And soon it escalates
from, "Okay, we need
this anti-discrimination,
we need diversity training,"
to, "We need active
anti-racism training."
And now you got Deborah
Max Kennedy in there.
And they figure, "Okay,
well, 10,000 bucks,
we can get these
people off our back."
Deborah Max Kennedy comes
in, spouts some bull crap
and we all move
on with our lives.
And they say, "Well, yeah,
but here's the thing,
you haven't established
the principles of equity.
We need hiring based on race."
And now you start saying,
"Okay, well, I don't
really like that but I'm also
afraid that if I fight back
against you, you might
file some sort of lawsuit
and claim that I'm
discriminating against you
and you might lead a walkout.
So I guess we'll go
along with that maybe."
And then it's everybody at
the company needs to put
out a black square.
Right, you can see how
it just moves along.
Because the more you give, the
more you're willing to give.
- Does that also tell
you a little something
about the human condition.
'Cause as you were talking
about that, I mean,
you could have given the exact
same examples with COVID.
It was two weeks to
flatten the curve.
It was, you know, a
month of lockdown.
Now it's a year
and a half later,
let's mask vaccinated people.
I mean, it's just
something about humans
and how much we just give
in the face of tyranny.
Right?
- I mean one of the great
lies about human beings
is that we're very
confrontational.
We are not.
We are very conflict averse.
And people who are conflict
seeking tend to be the winners
in this particular game
theory situation, right?
It's like the kid in high
school who's the craziest kid
no one wanted to fight.
And maybe you could
beat him in a fight,
but you never knew whether
he was gonna pull a knife.
And that's these people
working inside companies.
It's like, are they
gonna pull a knife?
Are they gonna knife you?
Are they gonna
knife your friends?
Are they gonna go after
the heads of the company?
Are they gonna tank the stock?
Are they gonna leak
to the New York Times.
Maybe we oughta just give
them this little concession.
- Yeah.
It's nuts.
All right, chapter two,
"How the Authoritarian Left
Re-normalized America."
I mean, we're
watching everything
being sort of
attacked right now.
- Yeah, I think that
the key to understand
how this went from sort
of small institutions
to the nation broadly, I
think the Obama presidency
was transformational.
And I think the reason
the Obama presidency
was transformational is when
Barack Obama ran in 2008,
he ran on the basis that he
was going to be a unifying
force in America.
He's gonna bring
together black and white.
There was no black, no white,
there were just Americans.
No red, no blue, right?
The whole shtick.
And then after 2008, he governed
very, very much to the left.
And there was the Tea Party
movement that cropped up,
there was this really hard
push back against Obamacare.
In 2010, he takes,
according to his own lights
a shellacking.
And by 2012, he's no
longer running as unifier.
He's decided, "You know what?
I can unify a couple
of different strands
in leftist thought.
One strand is the very heavy
government run progressivism
that begins in the
early 20th century.
And I can do that.
Right, that's my policy."
And then the other strand
is this kind of critical
race theory, far left,
burn it all down idea.
And these two ideas
have been in conflict.
Right?
The radical left had always
said, "Burn it all down,
we don't trust LBJ,
he's part of the system,
burn it all down."
And then you had sort
of the moderate left,
which was, "Let's spend a
crap load of money, we can fix
all problems with
the government."
Now those two things appear
to be sort of in conflict
with one another but Barack
Obama brought them together.
Because what he said is,
"Yes, I can do anything
with government, right, but
I'm actually tearing down
the system from the inside."
Right, I took over the
system, I'm one of you,
and now I'm gonna tear
it down from the inside
on behalf of all of
these intersectional,
oppressed minorities and
we're gonna cobble together
a coalition of the ascendant
and they're going to overwhelm
the old majority in
the United States
and we are going to win
for the rest of time.
And in 2012, when Obama did
that, right, he overtly pandered
to a wide variety of
intersectional groups.
He did, he did Dhaka in
order to appeal to Hispanics.
And then he did gay marriage,
remember, in 2012, right?
It was 2011, 2012, right
before the election
that he makes the shift on gay
marriage in order to appeal
to the LGBT coalition.
And then he starts making,
you know, overt plays,
for example, with regard
to, I believe he made
some overt plays with
regard to Asian-Americans
on certain issues.
And it was, he was one
of the first candidates
to have like specific
outreach groups
for every intersectional
coalition member.
And then the idea was, and
then we will all side together,
in the same way you see
this on college campuses,
to fight the institutions
and the powers that be.
Now the irony was he
was the institution.
He was the powers that be.
But this is why he kept
saying, we need to gut
the institutions
and remake them.
We need to remake
them from within.
You're getting the same
thing from Biden now.
We have to build back better.
It's not enough for us to go
back to the thriving economy
that we had a couple of, you
know, a year and a half ago.
No, we have to
build back better.
We are going to fundamentally,
re-change the institutions
by combining the progressive
power of the government
with this revolutionary
idea that the institutions
themselves are bad and
need to be uprooted.
- Right, and then we
hear like my governor,
at least for now,
Gavin Newsom saying,
this is the opportunity
we've been looking for.
So in some ways it's like,
yeah, they did all want this
because now federal bailouts,
suddenly California has money,
even though money
isn't worth much.
Inflation?
That's not a thing
anymore, right?
- Yeah.
I mean the basic idea from
the left has always been
that emergency is a ratchet,
it's a one-way ratchet.
And whether you're talking
about the Great Depression
or World War II, or
whether you're talking
about the so-called
war on poverty,
and certainly now every
crisis is an opportunity
to grow government.
And because the left
thinks not only in terms
of institutional control but
in terms of doing things,
right, the way that you
measure a good president,
according to the left, is
the president did things.
Now the way you measure
a good president,
according to the right, is
did they pursue policies
that were effective
in helping Americans?
For the left, it doesn't matter.
Right, the most
transformative presidents
are the ones who may have
lengthened the Great Depression
by eight years and interned
hundreds of thousands
of Japanese people but
they did a lot of stuff.
Right, and the same
thing with LBJ.
He was a terrible president.
He presided over to the
disastrous Vietnam War.
He presided over a tremendous
breakdown in race relations.
He did a couple of things
that were obviously very good,
the Voting Rights Bill
and the Civil Rights Act
but, overall, not
a good president,
but a transformational president
'cause he did a lot of stuff.
Barack Obama much less
successful president
than Bill Clinton.
Bill Clinton,
footnote to history
because he was too moderate.
Barack Obama hugely important
because he passed Obamacare.
And you're seeing the
same thing with Biden now.
This is Biden's
mentality with regard
to government action.
- So I have been thinking
something that I'm gonna drop in
this interview with
Ben Shapiro right now,
since you're bringing
up Biden and Obama.
My suspicion, and Ben, you
know, I'm going off the grid
in a week, but that the
Biden mental collapse
is so obvious at this point
that it can't hold much longer.
And I think they thought
they were gonna get
at least a year, I'm
not so sure they are.
That the way it's
gonna break the seal,
the way it's gonna actually
get into mainstream,
because we can all talk
about it but no one will talk
about it on CNN, et cetera, is
that Obama, in an interview,
is gonna say something.
He's gonna have a
one-liner saying, you know,
maybe Joe's lost a step or two
and then suddenly everyone's
gonna start saying it.
What do you think about
that crazy theory?
- I think the only way that
Obama does that is if he thinks
that there's a backup plan.
The problem for the Democrats-
- Oh, no meaning he'll
have a full backup plan.
But he'll be the one that is
basically gonna take out Biden.
- I mean, I think that if that,
I think if that does happen,
if there's a backup plan,
you're right that it would
be Obama who would do it.
He's the only person
inside the Democratic party
who is well-respected
enough to get away with it.
The problem for the Democrats
is they really,
really need Joe Biden.
I mean, they really
needed Joe Biden.
'Cause what's waiting in
the wings is Kamala Harris
and man is she unpopular
and man is she bad at this.
She is just garbage at this job.
And her job is really easy and
she's really terrible at it.
So I wouldn't, honestly,
if the Democrats had a way
of supplanting Kamala
Harris with Michelle Obama
I think that they would
try something like that.
- Yeah.
I'm just, I just have a
feeling it's gonna be Obama.
That's the one, that's
the airlock basically
because he's the one that
will just slightly leak it out
and then the plan will be there.
That is my almost
August prediction.
All right, chapter three,
you sorta hit on some
of this already, "The Creation
of a New Ruling Class."
That seems to be what this
is all about right now.
- Yeah.
Well I think this is really
about the university system.
So there was this sort
of presumption by people
on the right that what
happens in the universities
stays in the universities.
And that's not correct.
Basically an entire ruling
elite class was created
in the universities.
To understand why that
is you have to understand
what universities have become.
It used to be universities
trained you to be a good citizen
and also trained you for a job.
And now, unless you are what
we call the UCLA South Campus
major, right, a STEM major,
they're not training for either.
They're training you to
not be a very good citizen,
but they are training
you to be a membership
of the ruling class.
And the way we can tell you're
a member of the ruling class
is you speak the lingo.
This is what
colleges have become.
There's a reason, like what
did you learn in college?
I was a North Campus major.
Not much.
I came out with a credential.
What does the credential mean?
No credential means two
things, one I'm smart enough
to make it through college
and two, I've now been trained
in speaking the language
of the sophisticates.
And this is what you see
on Twitter when people put
their pronouns in their
profiles, for example.
It's the reason why people
put their college degrees
in their profiles.
It's because it is saying,
"I am a member of the elect."
Now what they hate more than
anything is if you're a member
of the elect but you don't
actually speak the lingo
or you don't like the lingo.
That's not okay.
But we've created this
sort of super powered group
of people who are
gonna run the world.
And we did it by sending
them to these institutions
where they rack up
massive amounts of debt
and learn what they're supposed
to say at cocktail parties
in order so that they
are well accepted
in the halls of
liberal intelligentsia
and in the halls of power.
And that's a real problem
because the reality,
I mean as Peter Thiel was
fond of saying, is that,
you know, college does
not educate you for a job.
We'd be much better off if we
had an apprenticeship system
in the United States
for most jobs.
And college is basically
a place where you go
to get a credential
and blow a couple hundred
thousand bucks and drink.
- By the time your kids,
who are all under 10,
by the time they make it to
college age do you think college
is gonna look anything remotely
like it looks right now?
- I don't know.
I mean, I think that by the
time my kids are in college,
I think that everything
is gonna be online.
I think they're
gonna be able to pick
and choose what kind of
courses they wanna take.
And I think, frankly,
that a lot of businesses
will have gotten wise to
the scam that college is
and they'll just start hiring
directly out of high school.
I think you're gonna
see people going back
to almost an old
model where they say,
"Okay, well you got
straight A's in high school,
you're obviously smart.
Come here and apprentice
for two, three years
and then we'll pay you."
- Chapter four,
"How Science Trademark
Defeated Actual Science."
This was making me think
of that great Fauci line
when he basically said,
"I am the science."
He went full Palpatine on us.
That's basically what's
happened here, right?
You challenge this guy and
you're challenging science.
- Yeah, and this is
the shtick of the left.
There are two problems
with regard to science
and the sort of move
toward authoritarianism.
One is the idea that
science is an institution
and not an actual
process, right?
Normally science is a
process, not an institution.
When you have Fauci declaring
Order 66 on everybody
who disagrees with him
it's obviously indicative
of a broader mindset.
The two big problems
that you see inside
the scientific community
are, one I label
the ultracrepidarian problem,
mainly because I love
the word ultracrepidaria,
but it basically just
means speaking outside
of your actual purview.
So you see this from,
for example, during
the last pandemic
when people said all of a
sudden that racial justice
was a health issue.
And you say to yourself,
"Whoa, hold up a second.
I'm gonna need you
to explain that one.
How exactly is racial justice
a public health issue?"
And there's no actual rationale.
It's just, "We're scientists,
we have a doctor in front
of our name, therefore
respect me when I talk
about race relations."
I said, "Well you
don't know anything
about racial relations.
I don't know what you're
talking about it."
So scientists speaking
outside their purview,
but using the imprimatur of
science in order to push it.
And this leads, in
reverse, to what I call
the bleed-over effect which is
where people will say things
that are unscientific
and then pretend
that the actual
science supports them.
And so you have this,
people who will say things
that are just political
but then they will say
that this is the science.
Right?
So that's what Fauci was
doing is he was saying...
You know, not, he was saying,
"Here is a political
perspective on what the rates
of herd immunity are,"
but politics is defining that.
But I'm now going to
say that that's science.
And that opens the door
to all sorts of bad things
being attributed to science,
even though they're not
actually scientific.
And so it's a really high
level form of gaslighting,
specifically because we all
do, science is like the last
institution that we
actually respect,
'cause it's verifiable.
So if you remove the
verifiability of science
and instead you make
it into an institution,
you guaranteed yourself an
enormous amount of power
but only by undermining what
science was supposed to be
in the first.
- Well they love science,
except if you ask them
how many genders there are.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Then it gets a
little bit confusing.
- Or whether a baby in
the womb is a maybe,
like a minute before it's born.
- Right, exactly.
Even though, as you
know, we're in the middle
of surrogacy right now
and basically a day after,
or two days after, they put
the egg and the sperm together,
we know the sex.
And it's like the
doctor's saying-
- How dare you?
You don't, you're projecting
the sex onto the child.
How dare you?
- It's not a click down menu
with, you know, 47 options.
This isn't specifically
within the book
but when I was reading
this chapter on science
I was thinking that
it's a little bit
sort of like your last
book which that this we're
worshiping science now,
perhaps instead of worshiping
God or having some set
of beliefs outside of ourselves.
Does that just seem like
the obvious conclusion
of a purely secular society?
That we'll just worship things
that will change every day.
- Yeah.
I mean, I think that's right.
I think that human beings
have a religious impulse
and something's gotta fill
that religious impulse
and why not the thing that
has brought us unbelievable
prosperity, high levels of
technological advancement,
it's prevented, up to
this point, disease
and death in extraordinary
numbers, right?
Why wouldn't you
worship that thing?
The problem is it's not
a thing, it's a process.
So you can certainly have
respect for the process,
but there have to be
some guiding values
beyond just the process.
The problem is that
people don't have a habit
of following the system.
They're more interested
in just appointing people
as their great leaders.
- Chapter six, "The
Radicalization of
Entertainment."
This is where you tell me
to cancel Netflix, right?
- You know, I don't say that
everybody should cancel Netflix
or Disney+, I just
say that you should go
and subscribe to Daily
Wire when we bring out
new entertainment content.
Because, listen, I
understand, I watch all these
same TV shows.
But the point about
the radicalization
of entertainment is just the
attempt, the pretty clear
attempt now to get rid
of full storylines.
The open attempt to throw
people out of Hollywood.
It used to be at least they
would try to cover it up.
The open attempt now
to throw people out
of Hollywood for not going
along with the program.
The amazing statement
that the Academy Awards
is now going to be predetermined
based on what color
are the leads in your film are
or what your staffing levels
are of a particular
sexual orientation.
It's absolutely insane.
And that does have a
rather marked impact
on how people think
about the world.
Because obviously entertainment
is very emotionally driven.
People tend to
think about politics
on the back of their
emotional state.
And so if the
entire entertainment
apparatus is taken over
by the left and it is not in
fact appealing to the market,
it is more acknowledging that
because it has a monopoly
in the market, it doesn't
have to appeal to the market,
whatever they
sell, you will buy.
If they know that they're just
gonna continue doing this.
- Do you think that we
can build better things
and eventually get to
the place where Netflix
won't be necessary and
Disney+ won't be necessary
and everything else?
- I mean, they have a
lot of legacy product.
I mean the reason that
I subscribed to Disney+
is not because I want to
see any of the new stuff
it's because I want my kids to
be able to see the old stuff,
and you just skip that
little warning at the front
telling them that they're racist
for watching "Lady
and the Tramp."
But, it'll take time.
I mean, Hollywood was
100 year enterprise.
So this is the bottom
line of all this,
this stuff takes time.
Conservatives are always looking
for like a turnkey solution,
'cause that's always
what we do in business.
But most of this stuff is stuff
that members of the left
have spent decades building.
- Right.
And the irony is it's like,
man, we need new stories.
We've discussed this
a million times.
But "Star Wars"
is basically dead.
They killed it now.
The Marvel movies
are basically dead.
They killed them now.
It's like, we just need new
stories if nothing else.
And then we gotta figure out
the way to get them out there
and the way to
put them together.
But we, but it's actually,
it starts with the story.
- It does.
And it also starts with
people who are willing
to actually put money
into these things.
And that's a risky endeavor.
I mean, Hollywood's risky.
And when business people on
the right think about business,
they don't think about Hollywood
because Hollywood
is such a risk.
And then the last person who
actually invested in a movie
and made money from it in
Hollywood doesn't exist.
Hollywood accounting
has its own term.
Right?
I mean, so it's
going to take people
who are really committed to
the cause to actually start
making entertainment
that appeals to a broader
spectrum of people.
- And by the way, that's
exactly what you guys are doing.
Right?
- We're doing our best, yeah.
I mean that's definitely
what we're focused
on at the moment, for sure.
- Yeah.
All right, we talked
about chapter seven,
but anything you want
to add on the fake news?
I mean, is there anyone...
Like, do you turn on
anyone at this point?
I thought Jake Tapper was
sort of the last hope at CNN.
To me, he's gone in all the way.
Like, is there anyone in
mainstream media at this point
that you're like, "Ah, you're
not completely horrible."
Which is all I would ask.
They can be mostly horrible,
but just not
completely horrible.
- Yeah.
I mean the way that I
tend to characterize
this is there are no
longer journalists I watch,
there are acts of journalism
that I will watch.
But what I mean by that is
that I don't actually believe
in the idea that journalists
are sort of a separate class
of higher human being.
Because I don't think they
very often follow the processes
of journalism they
themselves espouse.
And so I'm mostly looking
for people who commit acts
of journalism, and that's really
what Twitter is for, right?
Jake asks a good question.
You're like, "Okay, well
that was a good question."
It's not like I all of a
sudden, you know, buy hook, line
and sinker everything
that Jake Tapper tells me.
But when somebody commits
an act of journalism,
then they deserve praise.
And when they commit an
act of a journalisming,
then they certainly do not.
- Chapter eight, this seems
like the right way to end
this before we get
to the conclusion,
"Unfriending Americans."
We shouldn't hate everybody,
Ben, was that what your tweet
from earlier today
was all about?
- Yeah.
I mean, it's pretty easy.
It was amazing, I was talking
to some people on the left
about polarization
a few weeks ago
and people were
throwing around ideas,
many of which I
thought were silly,
like get rid of gerrymandering.
I'm like, "Well, we've
had gerrymandering
since the beginning
and I'm pretty sure
that our polarization is not
because of gerrymandering."
And I said, I have
a very simple thing
that all of us could do today.
Go online today, on Twitter,
find somebody who voted
for somebody that
you didn't vote for.
Right?
Whether, say Trump.
And then say that
person's a human being.
That's all.
That's the whole thing.
That's the whole tweet.
And nobody took me up on it.
Very few people on the left
I saw were taking me up
on this today.
I was seeing a lot of people
on the right were tweeting out
here are a bunch of people on
the left who I am interested
in reading and respect and
disagree with but I find
them an interesting person.
And I've yet to see anybody
from the left tweet,
in fact the only thing
I saw was somebody
from Media Matters tweeting
out my bad old tweets.
Right, to demonstrate
that I am not worthy
of being treated that way.
Because that's sort
of a radical asymmetry
where people on the right
tend to consider people
on the left mistaken,
but people on the left
tend to consider people
in the right evil.
That radical asymmetry is not
gonna be cured anytime soon.
- At what point does
that radical asymmetry
no longer work?
Like when these people lie
over and over, so when they lie
about Kavanaugh and they
lie about CRT and they lie
about election bills, and
we know they're lying,
and they know we're lying,
and they know we
know they're lying.
They continue to lie.
The whole thing.
At what point is it just evil?
Like really?
And I don't wanna get, you
know me, I don't wanna get
to that hyper partisan
place but at what point
do we just have to
call it for what it is?
Not to say there can't be
a couple of good people
who have different
political beliefs,
but that the machinery of
it is just endless lying.
- Well, I mean, I think
that as I say in the book,
the institutions
themselves have become
these sorts of
machines in many cases.
And so there are only two
choices, you can try to fix
the machinery from within, or
you can just pose alternatives
to the machinery
that out-compete them
and destroy them.
And when it comes to the
media I'm fully convinced
that there is no fixing
the New York Times,
there's no fixing CNN,
there's no fixing, you know,
The Washington Post.
You need to compete from outside
and you need to take them down.
And I think that that is
a worthwhile endeavor.
- Shapiro, we both have one
minute remaining, 60 seconds,
I want fastest Ben Shapiro,
white pill stuff right now.
Like how do people feel
good about all this?
That's the direction I'm
trying to go with this show.
And I know that's what
you're trying to do.
- I mean, I think the reason
that you can feel good
is because we have not
started to push back yet.
And I think a lot of people
on the right thought Trump
was the pushback.
No Trump was, you
went, you voted.
Now you have to actually
push back in the places
that matters in your own life.
You have to push back
on the school board,
you have to push back
at your corporation.
And believe you, me,
more people agree
with you than disagree
with you at these places.
Because you're not even
taking radical points of view.
When you say, I don't want
my business telling me
how to think about
how I'm a racist.
I don't want my kid taught
that stuff in school.
I don't think that I,
as a religious person,
ought to be forced into
participating in activities
I don't like.
Most Americans agree with you.
Which means that there
is fertile ground here.
The left has pushed so far.
I think they've pushed too far
and I think the blow
back is only beginning.
- Shapiro, you still got it.
- I appreciate that.
- And I think if you stick
with it, you're gonna make
something of yourself.
Good seeing you, brother.
- Good to talk to you, be well.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.